how everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back to let's play SCP
containment breach
alright so um the game before it cut off
because the game crashed and I forgot to
add the little two seconds of webcam
video that I added because I I said that
I wasn't gonna go back because it was
too late anyway but I'm back now and I'm
in the middle of a radical Larry's
dimension what God what God oh oh oh oh
hey ah yeah yeah I'm out I'm out with my
life I'm out in the office I got the
burnt note yes was this oh I'm over here
okay so anyway um look through this
thingy
we're gonna run smack into some SUVs but
that's okay no no no put that down
alright I'm gonna take off cuz you guys
don't like this gas mask no I can't run
forever use it wait what's going on I
thought I saw AHA there you are Oh what
was that I saw something coming down the
road out of my face
I gotta go that way screw that
yeah scp-173 okay
this way over here is a dead end on
what's what's over here anyway oh okay
so mr. big blocky is blocking my path
you're like what I call a bit blocky but
he doesn't like being called I'm all
tired from yesterday's 12 hour
livestream but that's okay hi hey big
fat headed ugly man haha I don't know
where I'm going I need to find game but
ha [ __ ] Joe
god dammit oh no I'm about to run out of
juice know that you owe 7 9 dare you I
shouldn't have given you could roll ok I
know
then now that I can use you use this to
upgrade my card in the machine but I
don't know where the machine is so
behind me
oh is this a machine hey go I yes it is
yes it is yes it is
Oh God ok going please
he's really aggressive and he can open
doors oh okay
so if I said it took fine then I put
dissing her or not very fine but fine
then crank this out
I think I should be able of grading to a
level five yep that's true it's a level
4 now wow I didn't know the machine was
like right here uh-huh
hmm hey hey pear league 18 is open which
means that I could my fine KP I could
get out gave me is an ending I think
yeah level 5 let's see if I can go up to
Omni huh
say what Omni probably not I'll get
she's a child
ash yeah you still there
yep that's an omni haha okay so I got my
Omni keycard I got the burn no it's
accent code on it
I got everything I need oh what's that
that's EEP I didn't leave oh wait I got
it is that that Oh God that's a way I
need to go I need to figure out what's
down there damnit guys after me okay ah
it's the house of the but ghosts okay so
if I go left
that's another path oh he's closing in
Oh got a good way to get a good way okay
so down that way yes I know I see B 1 m3
is all up in my grill but I need to
figure out where to go cuz I have this
Omni card and I have an access code I
need to figure out where to use it who I
can go up here now though OOP
oh yes oh what's this do Oh wicked
alright yeah hmm
Slendy
oh oh all right then
okay got a walkie-talkie now
let's see I don't know I don't know
where I'm going up completely forgotten
it's been a while since I pick this up
sorry for the delay I just happened I've
been busy with other stuff
ah dammit damn you guess what's on come
on come on come on
all Class D personnel are to be
terminated in the first of the month
oh my goodness okay I'm now back here
anyway
it's Lindy oh no can't get me I'm smart
for you there you are fo God does not
let office
oh whoa what whoa whoa oh my god us
what's your code wait get I'll get off
of that
five nine seven seven this WIU's into my
coat of this door actually yeah this is
- this is something else hmm okay but
but yeah that's just
I see the sat-nav it just leads down a
different path but but well maybe that's
the tunnels underneath it I'm seeing I
don't know either way I know I can go go
this way again blink aha hi hi there
by pepopepa - god this guy's not leaving
me alone he's just follow me everywhere
oh my seriously stop it stop it he's
alone I go this way I saw another path
down here and probably do more stuff I
know I see the offices somewhere okay
that's another gate that I can't get
through the gate B maybe no it's not
open okay not a ah nope radical area go
[ __ ] up I don't need you again good [ __ ]
you
okay that just leave down same way I was
on aha
what now vodka
what gun what ha ha no punch I don't I'm
not going back rad as Larry geez no oh
no oh no okay here he's coming but I can
get away from them alike Oh crapola
oh crap these are all dead ends oh crap
oh crap oh crap oh crap oh crap
ah oh no oh no oh no oh no f off I got
away from them need to relax
okay so anyway where the hell am I going
I don't even know I hear one 7:30 call
into the walls but if I if I'm here
that's the way I just came that way
there's another room but that just loops
circle like a serpentine pattern by
going here he's there damn it he popped
up fudge nutters okay if I go there yeah
it's just a useless loop so maybe I
don't know no I think I think if I go
through here then I come around a corner
and I get to the exit there yeah I
didn't need to go in there at all what
is this this is where the computer is
and this is blood yeah that's the other
end of it see who's just a loop crap
what was on the other side of this I
don't remember I don't remember I don't
remember I gotta check it out cuz yeah I
can't I literally cannot remember what
I've done sorry you can't see anything
oh this [ __ ] soldiers popped up out
of nowhere and got one hanging outside
the walls
Lesley's suit somewhere where does bleed
what is this
okay that's that I need to find radical
Larry's containment room cuz I need to
close him down
ah come on this is the other end of the
maintenance tunnel I don't think the
access code over here works either
what no it does not no access tonight
this isn't the right code for this door
okay I'm getting out of here I'm using
the gas masks are you can't see anything
but I need them be able to get places
quickly I need to all those soldiers
were like piled up behind that door I
think I need to go there I definitely
think I need to go there but if I even
open that door for a second they're
gonna shoot me and kill me very very
quickly so I am boomed seven threes
still hanging about I'm boned okay
says one seven threes like right next to
me nope
now today not today come on you soldier
bastard a wall over hangers abstracts on
ton of us
ah now come on boom boom ah boom oh
you're gonna walk through the portal
zoom oh what's this feeling you know uh
uh ha ha ha
fudge oh [ __ ] ah oh no come on I got one
in your place
ah no no how did it where did it come
from
this isn't fair I'm gonna dodge around
like a mouse like a mouse I see your
eyeballs
come on come on come on come on come on
come on
what Oh bro God yeah yeah I bet I can
kill those soldiers do that thing I bet
I can
who are they gone they're gone they're
gone
dr. Maynard - oh five nine that's a six
five nine seven seven did I put in a six
before ah no come on oh come on
huh huh oh no that's Maynard its Maynard
y-you know work [ __ ] what I did I did
want it to work and why I can never get
everything I want
Oh
oh I'm all out of time
oh alright thank I don't know what if it
bugged or something but thank you all so
much for watching maybe I need to update
my version because there's there was one
more update but I can't I can't transfer
my safe there's a memory access
violation every time I do to new update
haha alright knows nothing anyway so
I'll just try to get to gate B I think
that's the only thing I can do for now
so thank you all so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye